einordnen wurde jetzt nämlich verliehen
an ex-kanzlerin Angela Merkel Herr
Bruder sie sagen also den Orden den
hätte es jetzt nicht unbedingt gebraucht
da sind wir schon mittendrin in ihrem
Thema es war großartig und sie hat das
Großkreuz zum Bundesverdienstkreuz
bekommen ehrlich gesagt ich wusste gar
nicht dass es sowas gibt aber sind wir
einen Schritt weiter und ich frage mich
natürlich wie alle wie alle die ich
kenne dich treffen frage ich mich wofür
wo willst du das Kreuz bekommen schauen
Sie sie wurde gewählt völlig okay sie
hat einen Job gemacht sie war sozusagen
die leitender Angestellte dieser
Republik sie ist nicht von Gottes Gnaden
auf uns herabgefallen sie ist gut
bezahlt worden sie ist auch gut versorgt
sie muss sich keine Sorgen höhere
Zukunft machen es ist völlig egal ob die
Dose beukeller 1 € oder 1,50 € kostet
warum dieses Kreuz sie hat zu viel von
nichts gemacht meine peter hat es gerade
aufgezählt im internationalen Vergleich
sind wir wirklich auf dem Niveau eines
weltweit Landes aufgekommen